The sauce,
Kevin here with the ultimate representation of good and evil and Epic
battle of morality that has raged on game boards across the globe for over
2000 years, snakes and ladders,
wait, snakes and ladders, nothing but a really simple kid's game,
right wrong. While the rules are simple,
the math psychology and hidden spiritual lessons are surprisingly
complex. So to highlight that unique combination in a visual way,
I commissioned an intricate version of the game that harnesses electricity to
demonstrate the unpredictable gameplay,
the circuit that's made as we play will not only show the path to victory,
but will also.
Veal the meaning of life. Sort of this video.
I was sponsored by LG chem and this custom game board was created by
engineering, YouTube wizard, Alan pan.
The winner of this game of snakes and ladders will trigger this mystery
box to do something. I, I seriously,
100% do not know what's inside this box or what will happen
when the first player reaches the final score.
But we're about to find out together.
I do know that it's powered by 16 AA batteries.
Alan put it together in an afternoon and he promised me,
he promised that it will not burn down my house.
So that's good. Here's how it works.
Alan 3d printed red and yellow game pieces that contain about
50 feet of stainless steel conductive thread.
He's put a nail juncture at every snake's head and tail
on every ladders, top and bottom.
And at the end of each row on the board,
I'll start by hooking up both game pieces to this bolt and tightening
this nut down on it. I'll be red and you will be yellow.
And as we play, I'll wrap the steel thread around these junctures,
which we'll weave a path up ladders and downs snakes to show a
trail of each player's movement on the game board.
Here's the important part. When the winning.
Players piece touches a node on the final square,
that will complete a circuit to the battery powered mystery box and
whatever this thing does.
Will do. Hey.
Are we bothering with 16 alkaline batteries instead of using just a couple
of those powerful lithium ion cells,
because those lithium ion cells that kind of look like alkaline batteries
are not safe. When it comes to lithium ion cells,
they should be assembled into an battery pack with protective
circuitry, battery manufacturers like LG chem regard,
consumer safety as their number one priority.
And that's why they do not sell air sells to consumers.
Wait, what? Our bear cells.
Bear sales refer to individual lithium ion cells that are not incorporated into
battery packs with protective circuitry, lithium ion cells,
not embedded in a device with safety mechanisms made by credible manufacturers
are currently being used as a replaceable and rechargeable power source
in devices like flashlights, portable fans, vapes, and chargers.
If the cells insulating wrapper gets damaged while inserting and
removing these bare cells,
the negative can is exposed and metal objects like keys and
coins make a dangerous connection between the negative can and the positive cap.
This can cause a short circuit leading to a sudden release of high temperature,
gas, and flammable materials, which is called thermal runaway,
which is bad. No one wants that. So don't buy it. Don't sell it,
stay safe. Now let's climb some letters and slide down some snakes
or shoots. You probably know this game as chutes and ladders.
Since that's the name Milton Bradley gave it in 1943,
when it was important to the U S and sold for 50 cents,
I guess they thought snakes were scary and weird, which they are,
but to the game actually goes back much, much further than your grandpa, Joe.
It actually originated in India in about the second century BC and was
meant to teach children the importance of karma and comma
existences push and pull between one's destiny and the actions
that disrupt the path to that destiny.
The game play is obviously very simple.
The two players started at square one,
which may actually be where we get the phrase starting at square one,
and then roll a die for the player.
Then moves that number of spaces. If you land at the bottom of a ladder,
then you get to climb the ladder to that space.
If you land at the head of a snake,
then you have to slide backwards down to the snake's tail.
And if there's nothing on the space,
then it's the other players turn the first player to get to the final one.
Hundredth space wins. That's it.
That's the game in the official rules.
You need an exact role to reach the 100th space.
So like if you're two spaces away, you need to roll a two to win,
but I can get pretty tedious. Most people just call it a win.
When you roll at least high enough to get to the final space and I'll do the
same boards historically labeled ladders that advance your piece
with good virtuous actions like generosity or learning
adversely snakes were depicted along with vices, such as greed or gluttony,
navigate the snakes and ladders successfully.
And the winner escapes Samsara life's cycle of death and
rebirth to reach milkshake or salvation who knew what game
literally recommended for three-year-olds. Was this profound,
just looking at this board,
I can see that snakes are a lot worse than the ladders are
beneficial,
but how much worse we can figure out the breakdown of this boards.
10 ladders and 11 snakes from four to 16 is a plus
12,
12 to 33 is a plus 2149 to 51 plus
to add much of a help there.
And 88 to 92 is a plus four. All right, snakes,
21 to three, let's say minus 1852,
11 minus 39 93 to
25 minus 68.
It's like falling down a well and 99 to 58 minus 41.
All right. So the advantage of ladders,
we're looking at one 18 divided by 10 equals
plus 11.8 per ladder. And for snakes,
we're looking at three 88 divided by 11 equals
minus 35.27 per snake.
It's almost exactly three times worse to land on a snake than it is beneficial
to land on a ladder.
And there's an additional snake in there just to make it tougher because why
not? And this whole thing is probably just random. No, it's not an interview.
Roll message of this game is that it's harder to follow a
path of good than it is to follow a path of
bed. It's just easier to slide down into bad choices and bad
habits than it is to lift yourself up with virtuous deeds.
And as subtle as the games hidden moral lessons may be,
get a load of the unseen mathematical operation.
This absolutely ancient board game is actually a 101 state
absorbing Markov chain,
a series of events that depends on the state of the prior event,
which we first explored in per Rondo's paradox that could theoretically go
on forever, especially when you've got so many punishing snakes.
And if you want to make absolutely sure the next time you're playing this with
your five-year-old sister, Sally, that it doesn't last to nine hours. Well,
you can't. I mean,
it's not likely that a game will last the rest of your lives,
but with just the right combination of roles and snakes,
it actually could because snakes and ladders,
isn't a game of skill.
There's nothing you can do to speed up a win.
And there's no mistake that you can make to lose.
All you can do is roll and see what happens. Okay.
This is taking a while. What if I really,
really want to know when this game will end?
I can use board States and random roles to run a Monte Carlo
simulation that gives us the most common length of our snakes and ladders game
and the odds of any given length
Four, four, four. Yes, we are close. One,
two, three,
You one, two, three, four. All right. Look.
Uh, until this moment I have left this battery out for a reason.
I was worried that I don't know I would have messed something up and then this
thing would have done something.
And then I wouldn't have been able to put whatever happens back in here.
So the fact is we're at 98 and it's my turn.
And as long as I don't roll a one, it is the actual moment of truth.
I've reached the end of the board.
I've successfully ascended ladders and overcome the pitfalls of
evil snakes. So I'm going to put this battery in. Now.
It is fully charged,
as they say it is lit. Okay,
I'm going to move everything so that you get the best possible look at
whatever is about to happen. Next
don't roll the one. Don't roll a one. Don't roll a one. Don't roll.
One.
Okay. For, Oh, right. Oh,
I'm so nervous about this. Here we go.
[Inaudible].
It was, Oh my gosh. It was actual snakes. Well,
not actual steaks, but spring floated sakes,
the gearing up of it was actually almost as scary as the exploding
snakes themselves.
Snakes and ladders is a remarkable combination of mathematics and human
psychology.
That was invented centuries before the stochastic techniques needed to analyze
it were known, let alone two board game designers think about it.
A game intended for children needs to average just the right length,
too short. And it's not interesting enough too long,
and it gets boring snakes and ladders nailed this so
perfectly that thousands of years later,
kids are still growing up playing the game. And that isn't an accident.
Billions of people across 100 generations have played
snakes and ladders without even considering the deep story of
numbers, morality,
and the essence of human existence buried below it's
childish facade in describing the Hindu board game,
Lila, which is a 72 space version of snakes and ladders Haris
Johari said there is really only one game.
The game in which each of us is a player acting out
his role. And while, sometimes in life,
we land on ladders that launch us ahead.
And other times we step on snakes that slide us back.
You got to just pick up the dye and give it another role
because the game goes on until eventually you reach your goal,
whether that's reaching Nirvana or
triggering a mystery box of springy snakes,
and as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].
Hey,
I recently went to Philadelphia and shot a really cool video with LG chem
to explain the dangers of handling bare cells.
Lithium ion cells can release way, way more energy than alkaline batteries,
which makes them amazing when they're properly and safely enclosed in a
protective battery pack, but seriously, risky to handle when air.
So to see me walk you through how unsafe it is to use bare
cells and to just learn more,
check out the great video that I made with LG chem,
click the link down in the description below to do that.
You are going to really enjoy it.
You can figure out what to do with these pesky steaks.
Any device that requires a user to handle bare cells is
dangerous.
If the cells insulating wrapper is damaged while inserting and removing the bare
cells from the device,
the negative can becomes exposed and metal objects like a key
or a coin can make a dangerous connection between the negative can and the
positive cap,
a connection like this could cause a short circuit leading to a sudden release
of high temperature, gas, and flammable materials,
which is called thermal runaway.
And the result.